[Music]
got along Snoopy thinking about my
favorite equation by the end of say is
talk if you don't recognize that
equation you'll know what it means I got
into this business of the early universe
starting out as a particle theorist in
about 1978 I and a reasonable number of
particle theorists began to dabble in
the early universe a lot of our
colleagues at the time felt that we were
motivated mainly by jealousy of Carl
Sagan but I hope to make it clear during
today's talk that there were also some
motivations which came directly from
what was going on in particle physics
itself what I have in mind is the advent
of grand unified theories and to explain
that I'd like to give you a capsule
summary history of what was going on in
particle physics over that time period
ah when I was a graduate student back in
the late 1960s it was a period that
looking back on it now really looks like
the Dark Ages at that time we only
really understood one interaction of
nature electromagnetism the theory of
quantum electrodynamics had been more or
less developed since the late 50s and
that theory seemed to provide a far as
we could tell a perfect explanation of
electromagnetic phenomena but there are
three other known types of interactions
in nature the weak interactions the
strong interactions and also gravitation
and those interactions were really not
understood at all however the early 70s
were a period of tremendous progress in
particle physics the work of glasha
Weinberg and Selam was synthesized to
provide a unified model of the weak and
electromagnetic interactions and as far
as we can tell that model works
perfectly to describe those phenomena at
about the same time the theory of
quantum chromodynamics QCD was developed
to describe the theory of the strong
interactions as a theory of interacting
quarks and as far as we can tell that
theory also provides a perfect
description of the
that it was intended to describe so we
very suddenly went from a period where
we understood only one out of the four
interactions of nature to a period where
we think we understood three out of the
four interactions of nature ah that led
to an atmosphere of euphoria really
among the particle physics community and
it was a very strong desire to move
further to try to develop theories that
would describe phenomena and not yet
detect not yet found phenomena beyond
the range of our accelerators and the
guiding word behind that movement was
unification the idea that it would be
much more attractive to have a simpler
theory where there was one fundamental
interaction to replace these three that
we understood gravity all this time was
left along the side gravity at the
quantum level only becomes important at
much higher energies so it's safe on a
preliminary way to leave gravity out ah
however at the energies at which we do
experiments these strong interactions
are really quite a bit different from
the weak and electromagnetic
interactions and what that meant was
that in order to build a unified theory
it was necessary that the unification
occur at an energy which is very far
removed from the energies at which we do
experiments and that's what led to this
fantastic energy scale of about 10 to
the 14 GeV which is a characteristic
energy scale of these grand unified
theories now 10 to the 14 GeV that's
about three out of three orders of
magnitude beyond what Ken was talking
about in his last talk at the beginning
it's about the energy it takes to light
a hundred watt light bulb for a minute
which doesn't sound like that much but
again to have that much energy on a
single elementary particle is genuinely
extraordinary ah one way of seeing how
extraordinary it is is to try to imagine
building an accelerator to reach 10 to
the 14 GeV in principle you can do that
by building a very long linear
accelerator the energy of the linear
accelerator is just proportional to its
length so it's an easy calculation at
least to figure out how long the
accelerator would have to be and it
turns out that the using present
technology the length of the accelerator
would have to be almost exactly one
light-year now it seems unlikely that
such an accelerator would be fun
in the days of the gramm-rudman
amendment ah so what that means is that
if we particle theorists wanted to try
to see the dramatic 10 to the 14 GeV
scale consequences of these grand
unified theories we were forced to turn
to the only accelerator to which we have
any access at all which has ever reached
those energies and that appears to be
the universe itself in its very infancy
according to standard cosmology the
universe would have had a temperature
with KT equal to 10 to the 14 GeV at a
time of about 10 to the minus 35 seconds
after the Big Bang so that is the real
impetus for particle theorists to dabble
in the early universe now what I want to
talk about today is a scenario called
the inflationary universe and I'll get
there towards the end of my talk if time
permits there's a little bit of new
material which I may or may not get to
discuss I want to begin though with
basics I'd like to begin by reviewing
the standard cosmological scenario that
is without inflation so they can find
out what defects of this model the
inflationary model was designed to solve
now the standard cosmological scenario
is something that I learned about in a
course that I took as a graduate student
once at MIT of course that was taught
jointly by Phil Morrison and Steve
Weinberg I don't remember how well I did
in the course so if I get any of this
wrong it could either mean that I
botched it or may have been one of the
lectures that Steve gave but in any case
we can get it all straightened out
because my teacher is here to answer any
questions
ah the standard scenario is based on
several assumptions the first of which
is that the universe is homogeneous and
isotropic the universe certainly appears
to be homogeneous and isotropic the
evidence is of course not absolutely
compelling but the assumption that's put
into this model to make it simple is
that the universe is completely
homogeneous and isotropic ah the second
assumption which it has to do with
describing the early universe which is
all I'm going to be speaking about was
that the mass density of the early
universe was dominated by the blackbody
radiation of particles which were
effectively massless and by effectively
massless I simply mean that they're MC
I was small compared to KT so that the
masses were negligible ah third
assumption is that the expansion is
adiabatic that is no entropy no
significant entropy is produced as the
universe expands the universe essential
remains in thermal equilibrium fourth
assumption is that we understand the
laws of physics there general relativity
governs the gravitational field and the
large-scale structure and the small
scale physics is just dictated by the
physics that we know about how particles
behave at high temperatures when all
this is put together it leads to a very
simple picture of the early universe at
least to a boil which you can calculate
everything you want to know the
temperature falls like one over the
square root of the time variable the
scale factor describing the overall
length scale of the universe grows like
the square root of the time variable and
just to give you some sample numbers
that are relevant to people like me who
are interested in applying grand unified
theories to the early universe if we
look at the time when Katie was 10 to
the 14 GeV the temperature scale of
interest
it happened at a time of about 10 to the
minus 35 seconds as I guess I've already
mentioned the mass density at that time
was a colossal 10 to the 75 grams per
centimeter cubed that's the kind of
number that nobody would have dared
speak about when I was a graduate
student let me remind you that the
density of an atomic nucleus which was
about the dentist thing to anybody would
dare talk about when I was a graduate
student there's only about 10 to the 15
in these units so we're up another 60
orders of magnitude ah the size of the
region that will evolve to become the
observed universe at that time was about
10 centimeters now that of course should
not be confused with the size of the
entire universe we have no idea what the
size of the entire universe is it can be
arbitrarily larger than 10 centimeters
now even though I'm going to be
proposing a modification of this model I
do want to point out that the model has
some very important successes and when
we talk about modifying the standard
model it's of course also important to
make sure that you modify it in a way
which maintains the successes that the
original model had one important success
is that the standard model explains
Hubble's law if you have a uniform
system which uniformly expands if you
work out a little bit of arithmetic you
see that the Hubble's law immediately
falls out you get a velocity which is
proportional to the distance to any
given object the second important
success which has already been discussed
in Jim Peebles talk is that this model
explains the cosmic background radiation
because obviously if the universe is
expanding it means it's also cooling the
early universe would therefore have been
very hot and there would be thermal
radiation left over from this initial
hot period finally as Jim peoples also
discussed in much more detail the model
gives rather successful predictions for
the abundances of the light elements you
have a detailed scenario that tells you
how the universe cooled which means that
if you know a particle reaction rates
you can actually compute how many of the
different kinds of nuclei should have
been produced and there is one important
unknown parameter in that calculation
and that is the ratio of baryons to
photons but you have a number of things
you can calculate ah and the fact of the
matter is that for a reasonable value of
this unknown parameter you can fit these
various pieces of data quite well so
that isn't in addition the rather I
think spectacular success of the
standard model however I want to point
out that all of these successes of the
standard model only pertain to the
behavior of the model at times after
about one second after the Big Bang we
really have no direct evidence that the
standard model is valid at earlier times
so the inflationary model will we'll
make use of that fact and it will modify
the standard scenario only at times
which are in fact much earlier than one
second
okay let me speak next about the
problems of standard cosmology that the
inflationary model is intended to solve
I want to list four of them the first is
probably the best-known the horizon
slash homogeneity problem it has to do
with the fact that this cosmic
background radiation has been very
carefully observed and it's known to
have the same temperature in all
different parts of the sky to an
accuracy of better than one part in 10
to the 4 now normally when you discover
an object with the uniform temperature
you can tell yourself that's easy to
explain if you let a glass of water sit
on the table long enough it will come to
a uniform temperature but in the context
of the standard cosmology that
absolutely cannot happen for the early
universe there just is not enough time
one way of phrasing it is you can
imagine regardless of what physical
processes were actually taking place you
can imagine you had a network of little
green men scattered around the universe
whose mission was to arrange for a
uniform temperature and they have little
oven so they can heat things up when
they wanted to and a little air
conditioners to cool things down when
they wanted to but they could only
communicate with each other at a fixed
speed and what's easy to calculate is
that in order for them to achieve this
feat of arranging for the cosmic
background radiation to have a uniform
temperature they would have to be able
to communicate with each other at more
than 90 times the speed of light and
that is what's called the horizon
problem there just isn't enough time for
the communication to take place now this
is not a genuine absolute flaw in the
standard model the standard model still
works you simply have to assume in your
initial conditions that the temperature
was uniform at the start and then the
universe will continue to evolve with
the uniform temperature but what it is
is a serious lack of predictive power of
the standard model this very dramatic
feature of the universe this incredibly
uniform temperature throughout has to
simply be postulated it can in no way be
predicted or calculated on the basis of
standard cosmology and that's the
horizon homogeneity problem the flatness
problem has to do with the mass density
of the universe and I want to speak
about the quantity which everybody calls
Omega which is the ratio of the actual
mass density to the critical mass dense
now we still don't know very accurately
where Omega is today it's somewhere
between zero point one and two I think
many observers would like to put would
estimate much tighter constraints than
that but I won't argue with them I'll
just say that okay you agree with me
it's somewhere between zero point one
two I'm not worried about where within
that range it might be the point is that
Omega equals one is an unstable
equilibrium point of the standard model
evolution that means if Omega is exactly
equal to one or remain exactly one
forever but if it's a little bit off
from one it will immediately start to
move in that direction so it's like a
pencil standing on end
so to be anywhere is near Omega equals
one today which is a very late time in
the history of the universe it means
that at much earlier times Omega must
have been very much closer to one and in
particular if you go back to one second
which is not really an extraordinary
time in cosmology it's the beginning of
the nucleosynthesis processes at that
time Omega had to have been equal to one
to an extraordinary accuracy of one part
in 10 to the 15 in order for us to be
where we are today so what that means is
that in standard cosmology at whatever
time you want to start the universe if
you want to start earlier than 1 second
you have to postulate Omega was even
closer to 1 than that whatever time you
start the universe you have to postulate
that Omega at that time was
extraordinarily close to 1 in order for
the subsequent evolution to agree with
what we observe as far as I know this
was first pointed out as a problem in a
paper by Dicke and Peebles which I guess
came out in 1979 it's a fairly recent
consideration that this should be
regarded as a problem although although
I should add that the basic facts here
I'm sure we're known since the time of
Friedman in the 1920s
hey the third problem I want to discuss
I'll call the density fluctuation
problem the point is that although you
want to arrange for the universe to be
homogeneous on very large scales on
smaller scales are certainly
inhomogeneities that we observe galaxies
stars clusters this hotel and so on and
in order for that structure to form
there has to be seeds in the early
universe if you start completely uniform
the universe will simply evolve and
remain completely uniform in the
standard cosmology there is absolutely
no trace of a clue as what the seeds are
that formed the galaxies one simply has
to put in a primordial spectrum of
fluctuations in order to make the model
work so again essentially all the
important properties of the universe
simply have to be put into this model as
assumptions about the initial conditions
finally I move on to what I'm calling
problem for the magnetic monopole
problem of these four problems this is
the only one which is not a problem of
cosmology by itself this is a problem
that only arises when you try to combine
cosmology with these grand unified
theories the grand unified theories
predict that there should be particles
which are magnetic monopoles they have
extraordinary masses masses of about 10
to the 16 times the mass of a proton and
given the standard cosmology in the
particle physics you can try to estimate
how many magnetic monopoles would have
been produced in the early universe and
the conclusion that you come to is that
far too many magnetic monopoles would
have been produced so some modification
has to be found somewhere to suppress
this production of magnetic monopoles
okay.what that ends my summary of
standard cosmology what I want to do
next is to describe some properties of
the vacuum because it turns out that
understanding the vacuum really gives
you all the physics that you need to
understand inflation the vacuum used to
be simple back in the old days the
vacuum just meant the absence of
anything and nothing could be simpler
than that modern physics has changed all
that the vacuum is now about the most
complicated structure that we know of
and I'll elaborate on that
the dictionary definition is something
like the absence of matter or our space
empty of matter but that never really
was the physicists definition that this
definition is one which obviously at
least allows for complexity the
physicists definition of the vacuum is
simply given your theory of what
describes the universe what is the state
of lowest energy of that theory that is
what we call the vacuum and it may be
simple if you have a simple theory like
Newtonian mechanics the state of lowest
energy is just to take away all the
particles and then you have a very
simple description of the vacuum ah but
in more complicated theories the state
of lowest energy obviously has the
possibility of becoming more complicated
and that is what happens the vacuum
started to become complicated at least
so far as I know with the advent of
quantum electrodynamics in quantum
electrodynamics there are two things
that make the vacuum complicated
first of all you have the
electromagnetic field and the ultra
magnetic field in quantum
electrodynamics is constantly
fluctuating the reason is basically that
you calculate this by decomposing the
electromagnetic field into a series of
standing waves each standing wave acts
exactly like a harmonic oscillator and
as you know from quantum mechanics the
ground state of a harmonic oscillator is
not at zero energy it's 1/2 H bar Omega
so for each possible standing wave of
the electromagnetic field you get a
contribution of 1/2 H bar Omega to the
energy density of the vacuum
how many standing waves are there well
there's some maximum wave length if you
have a cavity and just talk about what
goes on in that cavity but there's no
minimum wavelength so you have an
infinite number of possible standing
waves an infinite number of
contributions of 1/2 H bar Omega the
energy density contributed by the zero
actuations is infinite so the vacuum is
not only complicated it already has
divergence problems this infinity of the
energy density is eliminated in the
theory simply by crossing it off your
paper you tell yourself that the zero
point of energy is not really relevant
to this theory anyway you can always
redefine the zero point at this level of
theoretical development it only becomes
a problem once you couple in gravity so
the energy density is simply redefined
so that the vacuum has zero energy
density however that's not the only
complication an addition to the
fluctuations of the electromagnetic
field
there are also fluctuations of the
electron field which one can describe as
the appearance and disappearance of
electron and positron pairs and since
they appear and disappear slow rapidly
they are they given the name virtual
particles and these give rise to very
real and measurable effects effects
which go by the name of vacuum
polarization the vacuum can actually be
polarized by an electric field because
of the appearance of these electron
positron pairs and that is a very
measurable and very real effect vacuum
polarization also gives rise to
infinities when you calculate it it
turns out though that all of the
infinities that the theory produces can
be absorbed into redefinitions of the
fundamental constants of course there
are definitions by infinite factors but
once you do these redefinitions then the
theory becomes finite and that process
is called we normalization and it's
process which is very very important in
our understanding of particle theory
today
now all this has a connection to
cosmology through the cosmological
constant it was as far as I know Zelda
which you first realized that Einsteins
cosmological constant can be interpreted
as nothing more nor less than a energy
density attributed to the vacuum where
the two are related by this formula now
if you take the empirical limit on the
cosmological constant and translate that
into an energy density you get a number
of about two times ten to the minus
eighth herbs per centimeter cubed it
should be sorry about the cube don't
have a pen here two times ten to the
minus eight herbs per centimeter cubed
for their bound on the energy density of
the vacuum now actually zelda in
his sixty-eight paper suggested that
there may in fact be a nonzero
contribution to the energy density of
the vacuum coming from the QED vacuum
now in order to make that work it's
actually very hard from at least from a
modern point of view if there was to be
a contribution you can try to estimate
by dimensional analysis how large it
would be and this is a very interesting
calculation which gives a what
originally at least was a very
surprising answer now it's known to all
particle theorists at least if just
using dimensional analysis the theory
really only has one characteristic
energy scale and that's the mass of
electron times C squared which comes to
about 8 times 10 to the minus 7 herbs
the theory also really only has one
characteristic length scale which is the
Compton wavelength of an electron which
is 3.9 times 10 to the minus 11
centimeters so if you try to make
something with the units of an energy
density you really only have one choice
you take that energy divided by that
length cubed and you get a number of
about 10 to the 25 herbs per centimeter
cube a number which is absolutely huge
compared to the bound that you have so
if there was some context in which this
calculation made sense you would have
gotten an answer that's obviously wrong
by a factor of 10 to the 33 so clearly
what's going on is that something is
preventing these kinds of mechanisms
from contributing to the vacuum energy
to the vacuum energy that we
actually measure nobody really knows
what that mechanism is and that's really
the important point I want to make here
in the context of QED most modern
particle theorists would have expected
an energy density to the vacuum of that
order the actual number is much much
smaller than that and we just do not
understand why the situation gets even
more complicated when we go beyond QED
to more modern Theory additions to our
theoretical arsenal the next important
addition and it really is a qualitative
addition is the development of the
Glacial Juan Berg Salaam model of the
weekend electromagnetic interactions
this is what is called a spontaneously
broken gauge theory it turned out that
the only way that we were able to think
the other not we they Steven shelia
Abdus the only way they are able to
think of to build a finite theory of the
weak interactions a renormalizable
theory of the weak interactions was to
combine it with the electromagnetic
interactions and to incorporate in the
model at the fundamental level a very
deep symmetry which would cancel some of
the infinities that would otherwise crop
up this symmetry though is not a
symmetry which we observe in nature if
the symmetry were manifest it would say
that the mass of the W and Z particles
would have to be the same as the mass of
a photon that is massless they're not
the W weighs 80 GeV the Z particle
weighs 90 GeV that's what makes the weak
interactions in fact weak
furthermore if this symmetry were exact
in nature it would say that an electron
would be indistinguishable from a
neutrino also a massless particle we
know an electron is not massless so this
symmetry which is a fundamental symmetry
of the Lagrangian of the theory
fundamental symmetry of the Hamiltonian
of the theory must not be a symmetry of
nature and that's accomplished by a
technique called spontaneous symmetry
breaking and it's done by introducing a
new kind of scalar field something
called the Higgs field in this
particular theory the Higgs field
actually consists of a complex doublet
two fields Phi 1 and Phi 2 each of which
are complex numbers now these are scalar
fields there's a good reason why you
have to use scalar fields to break these
symmetries because what we're going to
arrange is for these fields to have a
nonzero value in the back
if something like a vector field had a
nonzero value that would pick out a
direction in space and break rotational
invariance since rotational variance we
know is a very good symmetry of nature
if we want to break symmetries we have
to use scalar fields and the name of the
scalar field that does that is called a
Higgs field and it's done
by arranging for the energy density in
the theory as a function of the value of
the field to be a curve looks something
like this okay now the energy density
only depends on the sum of the absolute
squares of these two fields that's
imposed by the symmetry asymmetry says
it can't depend just on five one and not
by two it has to depend on them the same
way it has to depend in fact on
precisely this rotationally invariant
combination of Phi 1 and Phi 2 but what
you do is you arrange and you have some
freedom about this the theory allows you
to adjust parameters that control this
potential energy function and you adjust
the parameters so that the minimum
occurs not at zero but it's some nonzero
value okay now this immediately means
that the state of minimum energy the
vacuum is no longer unique because you
can minimize this curve by letting the
real part of Phi 1 have a value of 250 g
DV and all the other zero or you could
minimize this curve by letting the
imaginary part of Phi 2 have a value of
252 TV and everything else zero or an
infinite number of linear combinations
in between so there are many vacuum and
what happens in this theory is that very
early in the history of the universe at
about 10 to the minus 11 seconds the
universe settles into one of these
vacuum and the choice that the universe
makes at that time is the choice which
breaks this symmetry once say the real
part of Phi one acquires a nonzero value
and the others are all 0 that now breaks
the symmetry you no longer have a
symmetry between rotations and Phi 1 and
Phi 2 and that's exactly how the
spontaneous symmetry breaking works and
that's the entire purpose of having this
field in the theory in the first place
now you can estimate how much energy is
involved here I've drawn this curve the
way it's usually drawn contrived so that
the zero point
2news contrive so that the minimum lies
at zero energy density but the theory
does not impose that you do that by
adding and
trait constant to the energy once again
the real zero of energy is not really
defined it doesn't become defined until
you actually have a theory that couples
to gravity but if you were to estimate
the characteristic energy scale that's
involved here how high for example do
you expect the energy density to be here
and therefore how precisely did you have
to fine tune things for it to be exactly
zero there the characteristic scale is
taken by taking the same formula we used
for quantum electrodynamics where we had
the mass of an electron here and we
placing it with the mass of the W
particle the characteristic particle of
the Weinberg Salama model that has an MC
square root of 80 GeV and when you put
it in you get a number that's about ten
to the forty five herbs per centimeter
cubed so now we're too high compared to
the observational limits on the
cosmological constant by a colossal
factor of ten to the 53 we're not
finished yet
the next important development is one
that really highlights the inflationary
scenario grand unified theories and
grand unified theories you have a repeat
of the same story but you have to add a
much higher mass Higgs field a mess
Higgs field with a mass on the order of
10 to the 14 GeV and when you plug that
in to find the characteristic energy
scale that you'd expect to be developed
by this theory as a contribution to the
vacuum energy you get a number which is
too high by 108 orders of magnitude
we're still not finished I should
mention here that we're finished as far
as what we need to know for inflation so
everything that comes from here on in is
sort of trimming and I should also
mention I don't really understand what
comes in from here on in either but I'll
give you a brief summary the next most
sophisticated level of theory is super
gravity and the idea of super gravity is
that the fundamental scale is the scale
of gravity itself the scale you make out
of Newton's capital G known as the pump
mass which is 10 to the 19 GeV and when
you plug that into our famous formula
here to get here converted into a
characteristic energy density you get 10
to the hundred and fourteen herbs per
centimeter cube a number that exceeds
the experimental bound by a full of 122
orders of magnitude now we're finished
as far as I know
basically we're 122 orders of magnitude
off so what's going on is that there's
some mechanism that we
understand which is suppressing the
cosmological constant by about a hundred
and twenty two orders of magnitude below
what we would not evilly expect it to be
now I want to come in on what Jim
Peebles mentioned that particle
theorists are usually skeptical about
any notions that there might be a
meaningful cosmological constant that's
relevant to cosmology the argument is I
think not a compelling argument but
there is an argument and basically the
way I would phrase it it goes like this
if this unknown mechanism exists and
suppresses the vacuum energy by one
hundred and twenty two orders of
magnitude it seems highly unlikely that
it stops exactly there you think would
go for at least another two orders of
magnitude or maybe you know ten and any
of those would mean that the
cosmological constant would be
irrelevant the only way to get a
relevant cosmological constant would be
for the suppression to be exactly by
this hundred and twenty two orders of
magnitude which just seems unlikely now
as far as how to rate this argument I
would say that it's probably roughly
equivalent to the theoretical equivalent
to a three sigma experiment as we now
three sigma experiments you never really
know if you should believe them or not
same I think with this theoretical
argument
hey now I want to come to another
concept called the false vacuum which is
really what's going to lead us into the
inflationary scenario itself before I do
the curve for the energy density of a
scalar field which was then the Higgs
field which looked like this let's again
consider that we're dealing with the
particle theory which has in it a scalar
field which behaves this way and let's
ask ourselves what are the possibilities
when the scalar field sits on the bottom
that's the state of lowest possible
energy that's what we call by definition
the vacuum and the word true has been
introduced here just to be absolutely
clear that that's the vacuum however you
can ask yourself what happens at the
scalar field is perched right here right
on the top of the hill well if this
potential is quite flat on the top which
it can be it doesn't have to be then the
state where the scalar field sits on top
here can be metastable that is it can
live for a certain length of time before
the scalar field eventually falls off
and rolls down this hill and the energy
density diagram that state where the
scalar field is in the metastable state
at the top of the hill is what we call
the false vacuum it has an energy
density which is fixed by this curve
which is in turn fixed by the parameters
of the underlying particle theory and
I'll call the energy density of that
state Rho sub F F for false vacuum let
me go on and describe some of the
properties of this false vacuum first as
I mentioned the energy density is fixed
Rosabeth oh no matter what you do to it
you can't change its energy density
because its energy density just depends
on the fact that the scalar field is
sitting on top of that hill if you move
the scalar field you can change the
energy density but what we're going to
be talking about is changes which happen
too fast for the scalar field to move so
we'll consider the scalar field to be
temporarily frozen on the top and given
that the energy density is fixed okay
next thing to notice is that this data
is Lorentz invariant that is if you have
a scalar field which everywhere in some
region has the same value if you were to
move through that region and measure the
scalar field there's no way that you can
detect your motion relative to that
scalar field you would still find that
every place where you measure the scalar
field that had that value electron is
zero
so it's Lorentz invariant motion through
the state cannot be detected and that's
really the excuse for calling it a
vacuum in the first place false vacuum
and true vac you are the only states of
nature which have that property you
cannot detect motion through them
finally and this is what will really be
important for inflation the pressure of
this false vacuum state is negative and
in fact it's equal to minus Rho sub F